[Musik]
[Gelächter]
in der tat war politik insgesamt in den
letzten jahren eher krisenmanagement das
letzte kurzprogramm war vor der
schuldenkrise vor der euro-krise vor dem
verlassen der briten der europäischen
union vor der flüchtlingskrise vor der
dynamik der digitalisierung die wir
heute erleben
und deshalb ist es zeit unsere
grundsätze ins 21 jahrhundert jetzt noch
einmal neu zu formulieren
die cdu ist partei der mitte geblieben
aber sie hatten neue antworten gegeben
auf neue anforderungen beispielsweise
der familienpolitik wollen auch
bürgerliche eltern heute eine gute
kinderbetreuung und diese antwort zu
geben ist eine die nichts mit links oder
rechts zu tun hat sondern die auf
aktuelle anforderungen einer antwort
gibt
also es ist etwas absurd an einer
ressort verteilung einer regierung dem
markenkern einer partei abhängig zu
machen
der markenkern ist das christliche
menschenbild die soziale marktwirtschaft
aber nicht wer welchen posten bekommt
in der tat hätte man sich gewünscht dass
man das finanzministerium behält aber
was mich wundert ist wie die ringen mann
plötzlich das wirtschaftsministerium
chefs für mich als regierungschef an des
industrielandes ist es hoch relevant
dass der wirtschaftsminister jetzt die
energiepolitik der nächsten jahre
gestaltet dass er bei der gesetzgebung
im europäischen binnenmarkt regelungen
findet die unserer industrie und unseren
mittelstand helfen dass er sich für
mittelstand und handwerk einsetzt für
bürokratieabbau für digitalisierung das
sind alles themen die in der kompetenz
des wirtschaftsministers liegen und nur
weil die letzten wirtschaften liste
ihren job schlecht gemacht haben heißt
das nicht dass das ressort nicht wichtig
ist
[Musik]